In the previous video we talked a bit
About the immune system
In that video we focused on the non-specialized immune system
Or innate
So let me say that
Even the non-specialized immune system divides it
To the first line of barriers
They are things like skin, or infectious acids
Or acidic oils present in the outer part of your skin
These are natural barriers that prevent
Things get into your body, but once you enter them
You can imagine that this is
First line of defense
And then you have the second line of defense, but these
They remain non-specialists - and when we say non-specialist, we mean
They do not necessarily know what kind of viruses, ie
A type of protein, any type of bacteria
She just knows that this body seems mysterious
Let me take it
Let me kill him
Let me make an inflammatory response
In this place, we have said that there is a response
Inflammatory, which I will talk about after that
We finish the specialized immune system videos
You have your inflammatory response which is really
You bring things to the event site and then
You also have macrophages, which are cells
You swallow things
In doing so, all kinds of macrophages are occurring
In the previous video, they are all components of cells
White blood or white blood cells
These macrophages are here, all the kinds I talked about
Dendritic cells, macrophages and neutrophils
All are white blood cells
But not all types of white blood cells exist
We will talk more about it - and the other word used
The white blood cells are white blood cells
It is not specialized
It only prevents you from entering but when you enter
You say, stop, you're a foreign body
I will accuse you
I have receptors
And you have two double nucleic acid bars floating around
Viruses alone have two double nucleic acid strips
I will accuse you
I do not know which types of viruses you are
I do not know if I've seen you before
So they are not specialized
And now the most exciting thing about our machine
Immune - This non-specialized part exists in many and many
And many varieties and types of objects, but the specialized part
It is somewhat new adaptation
What I will talk about is the specialized immune system
Which is exceptionally and uniquely human
This is our other classification
Let me make her like this
If you have a specialized part or you can imagine
It is an acquired immune system
You might have heard of something like before
I have immunity against these bacteria or that virus
If this is the acquisition
It is actually built on exposure to these things
Regarding the immune system, we talked about it a bit
When we talked about molecules we knew about antigens
Carried out by macrophages - this plays a role here
We'll go into more details but I do not want to
To confuse you
But the key players here are lymphocytes, do not confuse
Because of white blood cells - because they
One of its kind
Let me say that
These are corneas
Specialized, but more specialized but both
White blood cells
Lymphocytes are another type of
White blood cells or white blood cells
I do not want to confuse you with this creepy painting, but
I want to make clear terms
When someone talks about white blood cells, it is
Only talking about the range of cells they found when
Try to separate the blood components for the first time - you will get
On your red blood cells that will be traced
At the bottom, then you will have this layer of white kind things in
The middle is actually made up of white blood cells
Here at the top you have a liquid, plasma of
Your blood, a fairly watery part
Hence the name came out, and they have
Other roles, but they interact with each other
Now lymphocytes can be divided into B lymphocytes, usually
B cells are called T lymphocytes
B and T come from the name of the place where these cells evolved
B lymphocytes were first identified in
Fabrichus pod
So called B
It is really a part of the bird body contributes to
immune system
Thus B comes from Barsa but B applies to
The human immune system because it is made in the bone marrow
This is an easier way to remember
It is manufactured in the bone marrow
It develops in the bone marrow but historically the letter B comes from
Vibricos pod, in case you want to learn
But easy to remember
The B can also express the bone marrow it is
The place where it was produced
T lymphocytes arise in the bone marrow
But it develops into what it is in the thymus
Hence the letter T
Now in this video I will focus only on the B cells
Because frankly if you focus on everyone
We will have a full hour video
But frankly B lymphocytes to some extent - a sense I do not want
To pick and pick favorite things, but there is something inside
Mental - I prefer B lymphocytes as per
B lymphocytes contribute to the so-called
Humoral response
I will tell you what the meaning of the humorous response is
You will see that the T lymphocytes contribute to the so-called
Response by cells and we will talk about them in
Video is coming
Are actually doing other classes of T lymphocytes
We'll see that there are T cells there and there
Cytotoxic T cells
I know that all this is confusing at first glance but
So I just want to focus on
This part is here
We will see in the future that T cells help
Play a role in multiplying and energizing
This humoral response
But the simplified way of thinking about the difference between
The humoral response and response by cells are
When I get injured, let's assume that I am
Have you had a viral infection okay?
At first when the virus enters my devices, just be
Immersed in liquids in my devices
The fluid in our organs is what responds to it
Capsules, for the humoral fluids in your body
If you have your viruses
These viruses are impure
If at the same time you are still standing, do not settle down
Within cells, there is a humoral response
Appear in place
The same is true if we have small stray bacteria
You have not entered the cells yet
Are just hanging in the liquid, here will be
The humoral response is useful
Now, if we are surprised that they have entered the cells
If the cells are now infected with the virus
Viruses are produced using existing keystones
In the cell to give more and then suddenly we have to be
Sophisticated in dealing with these
Cells with these viruses will not
Be just bewildered anymore
I think we would be willing to kill this cell even though it was
One of our cells but now helps in the manufacture of viruses
Or may be colonized by bacteria
So in both cases, you want to kill her
I will talk more about cell response